enthalpy of formation refers to the
change in enthalpy
for the formation of one mole of a
substance
from the most stable form of its
constituent elements
change in enthalpy is symbolized by
delta h and the f
stands for formation and the the
superscript
naught refers to the fact that
everything is under standard state
conditions which refers to
atmospheric pressure of one atmosphere
and a specified temperature that is
usually 25 degrees celsius
so when we're thinking about standard
enthalpy of formation
we're thinking about the elements and
the state that they exist under standard
conditions
so the elements have to be in their
standard states so let's think about
forming
one mole of carbon dioxide
so carbon dioxide is composed of the
elements carbon and
oxygen and under standard conditions the
most
stable form of carbon is
graphite so we're going to write carbon
in the solid state
and we're going to write graphite over
here and
next when you think about the most
stable form of
oxygen under standard conditions and so
at one atmosphere
so atmospheric pressure and room
temperature of 25 degrees celsius the
most stable form of oxygen
is oxygen gas so we can go ahead and
write in here
o2 and since we're forming one mole of
carbon dioxide
from the elements that make up carbon
dioxide in their
in their most stable form under standard
conditions
the change in enthalpy for this would be
the standard enthalpy of formation so we
have our subscript f
and our superscript naught to indicate
standard conditions
the change in enthalpy for the formation
of one mole of co2
is equal to negative 393.5
kilojoules per one mole of carbon
dioxide
let's look at some more equations
showing the formation of one mole of a
substance
for example let's look at the equation
showing the formation of one mole
of water so water is composed of
hydrogen and oxygen and the most stable
forms of those two elements under
standard conditions are hydrogen gas
and oxygen gas and for the coefficients
to make
to make one mole of water we need a
one-half as our coefficient in front of
o2
the standard change in enthalpy of
formation for the formation of one
mole of water is negative 285.8
kilojoules per mole
we can do the same thing for the
formation of one mole of methane
ch4 we already know that the most stable
form of carbon is graphite and the most
stable form of hydrogen is hydrogen gas
and the standard change in enthalpy of
formation
for the formation of one mole of methane
is equal to negative 74.8 kilojoules per
mole
next let's think about forming one mole
of oxygen
gas well we're forming the oxygen gas
from the most stable form of oxygen
under standard conditions which is also
diatomic oxygen gas
o2 so we're not changing anything we're
going from o2 to o2 and since there's no
change there's no change in enthalpy
therefore the standard enthalpy of
formation
is equal to zero and this is true for
the most stable form of any element the
standard enthalpy of formation of the
most stable form of any element
is zero since you'd be making it from
itself
standard enthalpies of formation in
kilojoules per mole are often found in
the appendices
of many textbooks and if you look in the
appendix of a textbook you'll see
the standard enthalpy of formation for
diatomic oxygen gas o2
is equal to zero ozone which is o3
also exists under standard conditions
however it's not the most stable
form of oxygen under standard conditions
and therefore
its standard enthalpy of formation is
not zero it's 142.3
graphite is the most stable form of
carbon under standard conditions
therefore it has a standard enthalpy of
formation of zero
but of course diamond also exists under
standard conditions
but it's not the most stable form so its
standard enthalpy formation
is not zero it's 1.88 kilojoules per
mole enthalpies of formation can be used
to calculate the change in enthalpy for
a chemical reaction
we can do this by using the following
equation the
standard change in enthalpy for a
chemical reaction
is equal to the sum of the standard
enthalpies of formation of the products
minus the sum of the standard enthalpies
of formation
of the reactants let's say our goal is
to find the standard change in
enthalpy for the following chemical
reaction so we have one mole of methane
reacting with two moles of oxygen to
form
one mole of carbon dioxide and two moles
of water
the first thing we need to do is sum all
the standard enthalpies of formation of
the products
so if we look at our two products over
here we'll start with one
mole of carbon dioxide so let's go ahead
and write this down here we have one
mole of carbon dioxide
and the standard molar enthalpy of
carbon dioxide we've already seen is
negative 393.5 kilojoules per mole of
carbon dioxide
so we're going to multiply one mole of
carbon dioxide by
negative 393.5
kilojoules per mole of carbon dioxide
our other product is two moles of water
so we're going to add this to the other
one so we have two moles
of h2o and the standard enthalpy of
formation of h2o is negative 285.8
so we're going to multiply this by
negative 285.8
kilojoules per mole
so moles cancel out and we get negative
393.5 kilojoules
and if the other one moles cancel out
again and this would be plus
negative 571.6
kilojoules which is equal to negative
965.1
kilojoules so that's the sum of
all of the standard enthalpies of
formation of our products
next we need to sum the standard
enthalpies of formation of our reactants
so the two reactants that we have
are methane and oxygen and we have one
mole of methane so let's go ahead and
write that in here so we have one mole
of methane
the standard molar enthalpy of formation
of methane is negative 74.8 kilojoules
per mole
so we're multiplying one mole by
negative 74.8
kilojoules per mole
our other our other reactant is oxygen
and we know that diatomic oxygen gas has
a standard enthalpy of formation of
zero so we could go ahead and write this
in just just to show it
so we have two moles of oxygen but we're
multiplying that number by
zero so moles cancel and give us
negative 74.8 kilojoules
and we're adding zero to that so
negative 74.8
kilojoules is the sum of
all the standard enthalpies of formation
of our reactants
so to find the standard change in
enthalpy for our reaction we take the
summation
of the enthalpies of formation of our
products which was negative 965.1
kilojoules
and from that we subtract the sum of the
standard enthalpies of formation of the
reactants which we found was negative
74.8 kilojoules
so negative 965.1 minus negative 74.8 is
equal to negative
890.3
kilojoules for the units sometimes you
see kilojoules sometimes you see
kilojoules per mole
and sometimes you see kilojoules per
mole of reaction and what kilojoules per
mole of reaction means is how the
balanced equation is written
for this balanced equation we're showing
the combustion of one mole
of methane so combusting one mole of
methane releases
890.3 kilojoules of
energy so that's what kilojoules per
mole of reaction is referring to
let's go back to the step where we
summed the standard enthalpies of
formation of the products to see how we
could actually get kilojoules per mole
of reaction
as our units to do this we need to use a
conversion factor
for how the equation is written we're
producing one mole of carbon dioxide so
we can use as a conversion factor
there's one mole of carbon dioxide per
one mole of reaction
we can do the same thing for our other
product which is water
for how the equation is written we're
forming two moles of water
so our conversion factor can be there
are two moles of water
for every one mole of reaction
next moles of carbon dioxide cancels out
and
moles of water cancel out and this gives
us kilojoules per mole of reaction
as our units it's a little more time
consuming to write out all the units
this way
so often it's faster to do it the first
way and add in these units at the end